[Music]
breaking news this wednesday night
we charity shuts down in canada what's
happening to the organization
immersed in controversy warnings about a
second wave
we are not out of the woods rising
covid19 cases that could lead to
restrictions being reimposed
plus how to avoid getting the flu during
the pandemic
multi-million dollar investment we added
disadvantage
federal support for black canadians
building their businesses
and america's exploding wildfires
towering flames and choking smoke roar
through the west coast
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news about
we charity the organization at the heart
of the latest ethics investigation
involving prime minister justin trudeau
we charity is shutting down its canadian
operations and its co-founders brothers
craig and mark kielberger
are stepping away the charity ran into
trouble after the liberal government
awarded it a sole sourced multi-million
dollar contract to run a student
volunteer grant program
that contract was pulled and the close
relationship between the charity and
trudeau his family plus the former
finance minister bill morneau
has come under intense scrutiny abigail
beeman is in ottawa with more details
abigail what reasons are the keel
burgers giving for shutting down the
charity they started
donna in a statement released this
evening the kielburgers point to two
things the pandemic
and the politics which the founders say
they are ill-equipped to fight
over the past seven months we charity
has experienced a series of
unprecedented challenges and so to
protect
the beneficiaries to protect the
projects
that we created around the world we will
be closing
wheat charities operations in canada
as the kielbergers often point out this
all started 25 years ago with the idea
of children helping other children in
developing countries around the world
with a variety of different community
projects
the organization has already had layoffs
and a board turnover over the past few
months
in their testimony on parliament hill
the kielbergers talked about the big
impact the pandemic has had on their
bottom line there's still
a big question here over how much of
this decision is due to the pandemic
or due to the political storm that
erupted over the canada student service
grant
the deal worth nearly 1 billion dollars
with we standing to earn up to
forty three and a half million dollars
it emerged the organization
got that government deal after members
of justin trudeau's family
including the prime minister's mother
brother and wife were paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars in speaking fees
the deal in the end was canceled
the grant program never never got off
the ground tonight the prime minister's
office tells us it has no comment about
the news
while the ethics commissioner's office
says the commissioner is focused on the
two investigations still underway into
the prime minister
and the former finance minister bill
morneau the news about we doesn't change
that
and abigail we charity runs a number of
humanitarian programs overseas that help
children who live in poverty
do we know what's happening to those
programs that's an important point in
all of this as for those international
aid
projects we is planning to sell off
assets including its toronto
headquarters
they say they'll use the money to fund
an endowment to keep
those projects going the endowment will
also allow them to keep the curriculum
and other material developed over the
past 25 years accessible
on the website but the killburgers say
there will be no
new school water or health projects
developed
donna okay abigail beeman in ottawa on
the we
charity thank you shifting now to the
covet 19 pandemic and the challenges
emerging as countries navigate how to
keep the virus from spreading
and avoid bringing back tighter public
health restrictions here in canada
it's already happening new rules for
bars and restaurants and nightclubs are
coming into force in british columbia
other provinces with rising case numbers
are weighing their options
and watching countries like england
which is reimposing restrictions
most social gatherings larger than six
people are being banned there
more on that in just a moment here in
canada with infections on the upswing in
a number of places the public is being
reminded
to take covid19 seriously or face the
consequences
the last thing that anyone wants
is to have to once again shut down our
economies
and suspend our lives to try and counter
a massive second wave here's the picture
on new infections reported today there
were no new cases in atlantic canada
with the exception of pei where there
were two new infections
the province with the most new cases
today was quebec 180.
there were 149 new cases in ontario 98
in alberta and 100 in british columbia
in that province new measures are coming
into effect to try to prepare for what's
feared the fall and winter might bring
apart from those new restrictions
shutting down nightclubs and banquet
holes
the province is pumping hundreds of
millions of dollars into its health care
system
global's keith baldry is in victoria
tonight keith what's that money going to
be spent on
it's a fair amount of money donna 1.6
billion dollars
largely to hire a lot of people in the
health care system two thousand people
are gonna be hired to help seniors in
long-term care homes
five thousand people going to be trained
as health care aides in hospitals
cleaners and food supply workers but the
centerpiece of the plan is to purchase
2 million doses of vac flu vaccine for
the upcoming influenza season and dr
bonnie henry the provincial health
office
officer today pointed out this is the
largest immunization program we've ever
seen in bc here's a doctor
our fall influenza campaign is going to
be on a scale that we have not yet seen
to further protect people who are
vulnerable in this province
and we encourage everybody who's over
the age of six months
to be immunized for influenza so again
that flu vaccine is going to be
widely distributed an expectation we're
never going to see a higher number of
vaccinations than we're going to see
this year
interestingly back to those 7 000 people
are going to be hired donna uh all of
them the priority is to hire people
who've been laid off in the pandemic in
their
service and hospitality sectors that's
been hit the hardest those people will
get first crack at these jobs the
biggest hiring
uh program bc has ever seen is taking
place in this pandemic
all right keith baldry in victoria thank
you
in the uk tighter covid19 restrictions
are being reimposed on monday
prime minister boris johnson revealed
the new rules in his first coronavirus
briefing since july
the so-called rule of six is coming back
limiting most social gatherings to just
six people
police will enforce the measures and
issue fines or make arrests if needed
johnson also floated the idea of a rapid
test like a pregnancy test for covet 19
that people could take every morning
and he claimed it's still possible to
get life back to at least closer to
normal
by christmas i want to be absolutely
clear this is not these measures are not
a
another national lockdown
the whole point of them is to avoid
a second national lockdown
the rule of six does not apply to
workplaces or schools in england and
there will be exemptions for weddings
funerals and some organized team sports
more than 2600 new coven 19
cases were reported in the uk today
there's been a setback in the human
clinical trial of a vaccine for covet
19.
pharmaceutical giant astrazeneca is
pausing the final phase of its clinical
trial
because of an adverse reaction in one of
the participants there are reports the
person experienced neurological symptoms
consistent with a spinal inflammatory
disorder
the company which is working with oxford
university is now looking into whether
the illness is a side effect of the
vaccine trial
or a coincidence pausing trials is not
unusual during vaccine development when
there's an unexplained illness
it's unclear how long the investigation
will take the highly anticipated vaccine
was expected to be available
as early as january another book is
coming out about what's claimed is
really going on
inside the trump administration this one
doesn't rely only on anonymous sources
and is backed up by audio recordings
including of president
trump himself it reveals that back in
february when he was telling the nation
covid 19 is no worse than the flu and
would soon disappear
he knew that wasn't true yet he
deliberately misled the public
more than and ninety thousand americans
have now died of covid19
the u.s has the most cases and most
deaths of any country in the world
the book is called rage it's written by
washington post associate editor bob
woodward
jackson proskow explains what it reveals
but i think it's going to work out good
we only have 11 cases and they're all
getting better
while the president was busy downplaying
the threat of covid 19 in public
there's no reason to panic because we
have done so good in private he
expressed alarm to veteran journalist
bob woodward in a series of recorded
interviews
in early february trump explained he
clearly understood the risks of the
virus
admitting kovid 19 was highly contagious
deadlier than the flu it goes through
air bob that's always tougher than the
touch you know the touch you don't have
to touch things right but the air
you just breathe the air and that's how
it's passed
and so that's a very tricky one that's a
very delicate one
uh it's also more deadly than your you
know
your even your strenuous flus two weeks
later
this is what trump told reporters and
they recuperate like if you have the flu
you recuperate
you get better in a later interview
trump acknowledged purposely downplaying
the threat
i wanted to i wanted to always play it
down
i still like playing it down yes because
i don't want to create a panic
that was long before 190 000 americans
had died from the virus
well i think if you said in order to
reduce panic perhaps that so the fact is
i'm
a cheerleader for this country the
problem is now worse in the u.s than in
any other country
trump still insists there was no way to
prepare
you didn't really think it was going to
be to the point where it was
his rival joe biden seized on the
revelations
which are now likely to dominate the
campaign he had the information
he knew how dangerous it was now while
this deadly disease ripped through our
nation
he failed to do his job on purpose
jackson there have been other tell-all
books about trump and his administration
what makes this one different
well what's different donna is hearing
from trump directly in his
own words on tape about an issue that
impacts every single person in this
country
whether through the pandemic itself or
the devastating economic collapse and
donna we've been told
more damaging drops from this book could
come in the weeks leading up to the
election
all right jackson in washington thank
you the pandemic has disproportionately
affected
black canadians it's highlighted
inequalities that have existed and
persisted for generations
including for black canadians who want
to start their own businesses
a statement from the parliamentary black
caucus makes this point it says
it is hard to change what one cannot
measure for too long the socio-economic
realities faced by black communities are
invisible because of a comprehensive
lack of data
today the prime minister announced a
multi-million dollar program to collect
that data
and to help break down barriers systemic
racism
has created eric sorenson reports
little jamaica a largely black business
community in toronto
has been hit hard by major subway
construction and by the downturn from
covert 19.
but all of that comes on top of decades
of systemic racism towards black
businesses in this country
the cost of running a business as a
local business or as a black
entrepreneur is higher
the benny boo fashion shop has faced
barriers like higher insurance premiums
that make it hard for black businesses
like this
to get loans from major banks we had a
disadvantage
being a black entrepreneur financial
benefits are not
readily and easily available to us given
certain systematic discriminations
earlier this summer the prime minister
promised to address injustices
faced by people of color now he's met
with black business leaders to announce
a new program with major canadian
lenders
to address the financial barriers black
people face the program includes a
federal fund up to 53 million dollars to
help black entrepreneurs with financial
planning
training and mentorship the biggest part
along with ottawa major lenders will put
up the lion's share of 161 million
dollars
to provide loans up to 250 000 dollars
specifically for black businesses
by working with financial institutions
there is much
greater access to capital for
these black businesses which face
systemic barriers and discrimination
every single day we have been shouting
that from the mountaintops
andrea barrett of the canadian black
chamber of commerce says the racial
injustice seen this year has been a
wake-up call for
governments and the big banks it's not
always the same for a black person as is
for
someone who is in black we're pleased
with today's announcement and pleased
that the financial institutions are
involved there's little data on
discrimination towards black
entrepreneurs in canada
so the federal program will also create
a knowledge hub
to identify both barriers and
opportunities for growth
how and when yes benny bucca remains
skeptical of big lenders
but she hopes systemic barriers to black
businesses
are finally being addressed eric
sorensen global news toronto
the battle for democracy in belarus
coming up why this nobel laureate called
for diplomatic backup to protect her
from arrest
it has been exactly one month since that
disputed election in belarus and the
crackdown against opposition activists
is intensifying only one member of the
opposition's coordination council
remains free in belarus and her freedom
is very much in limbo as redmond shannon
reports
it's rare that any public figure would
welcome a barrage of
cameras at their front door
nobel literature laureate and opposition
activist svetlana alexevic
told reporters masked men tried to break
into her apartment
on wednesday note her reinforced door
after the incident european diplomats
came to show their support for the last
member of the opposition's coordination
council to remain
free and inside belarus earlier
wednesday maxim's knack was taken into
custody
it follows the mysterious detention of
maria kolesnikova at the ukraine border
this week fellow council members said
she tore up her passport to avoid being
deported with them
their exiled leader svetlana
tiganovskiya was in warsaw wednesday
eu member nation poland donating a city
building to the opposition movement
i will try to answer you why our
protests
are so unique now first of all
it's led by women and supported
by women for a second day running masked
belarusian police
arrested groups of female protesters
over the weekend hundreds of people were
arrested and many were allegedly beaten
i know somebody who was going to go but
then she changed her mind because she
was
quite afraid which is understandable
this canadian in belarus worries he
could be deported if we reveal his
identity
one of the fears i have is you know you
take the other guy i'll take the subway
and you accidentally come out at the
wrong metro station
and you find yourself being arrested for
being at the wrong time at the wrong
place
president alexander lukashenko told
russian tv his
26 years in power may have been too long
but says he won't step down
he again spoke of interference from the
west suggesting he's being watched by
american satellites
since the disputed election he has
looked east to moscow for support
the protesters of belarus stuck in the
middle insist
they just want free and fair elections
redmond shannon global news
london this is what driving through san
francisco looks like right now coming up
the fires
ripping through the west coast
drivers across utah witnessed this
yesterday at least 45 semi trucks were
blown over by hurricane force winds of
more than 120 kilometers an hour
four drivers were hospitalized officials
say many of the drivers had ignored
warnings
about the high winds powerful winds
along the u.s west coast are whipping up
flames and preventing
fire crews from containing a line of
fires that now stretches
from california to just south of the
canadian border the smoke has triggered
air quality advisories for the vancouver
area and other regions
in southwestern british columbia the
situation on the ground in parts of
washington state is dire
and one town a fire destroyed 80 percent
of buildings
including the local fire station
and this explosion in oregon happened
last night as a wildfire roared along a
highway south of portland
thousands of people have been forced
from their homes the record-setting
outbreak of fires in the state has
scorched more than 80 thousand hectares
of land
in california about 10 times that much
land has burned and thousands of homes
and businesses have been destroyed
and the smoke made for an eerie site in
san francisco
bay area residents woke up to this a
blanket of thick orange haze
blocking the morning light people in
some areas reported ash
falling like snow there are more than 40
fires burning some started weeks ago
it's been extremely hot in california
and high winds fanning the flames are
expected to continue
into tomorrow
tonight we honor hollywood's best and
widest sorry brightest
next how the oscars are changing to
increase diversity
the biggest award in the movie business
is making a change the oscars are adding
new criteria films must meet in order to
be eligible
in the best picture category the goal is
to improve diversity and inclusion
on both sides of the camera mike
armstrong explains
there have always been criteria for a
movie to be considered for best picture
and some of them are a little strange
for example it has to have been
advertised
specifically in los angeles on something
like a billboard
well the new criteria announced
wednesday have a more
obvious goal the academy wants to
increase the presence
and visibility of women people from
racial or ethnic groups the lgbtq plus
community
and people with cognitive or physical
disabilities
and i want to thank everyone for joining
us the oscars released a series of
videos over the last week
explaining how too often the industry
comes up short
cinema is really it's like the home
movie
of the world isn't it really it's where
we go we see ourselves and we're not
there
and when we are there we're horribly
misrepresented
got room for one mo now it's not the
highest bar to have to get over
there are four new criteria for a movie
to be considered in the best picture
category and it only has to meet two of
them
the first is on screen standard a sets a
threshold for actor representation and
storyline
the rest are behind the camera standard
b's about the film's creative leadership
and project team
standard c's about internships and
training opportunities
and ds about the group behind the
marketing publishing and
distribution this move
comes after years of controversy and
criticism the recent oscars so white
campaign
even made it into the broadcast tonight
we honor hollywood's best
and widest sorry brightest they
finally listened ella maya tail feathers
says the academy may have been pushed
but it's a positive step
the indigenous filmmaker says when
people from her community aren't seen on
screen
or on set it isn't a lack of voices or
talent
it's a lack of opportunity this pushes
production companies to not be lazy in
the way that they hire
and the way that they operate well take
care ladies tell feathers says she hopes
in 10 years to have the freedom
white men have to talk simply about
their work
instead of having to talk over and over
about difficulties
getting work mike armstrong global news
montreal and that is global national for
this wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is the sunset in
steep rock manitoba
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
and thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye
[Music]
you